crise en nouvelle calédonie laurent
fabius annonce l'envoi de renforts pour
assurer l'ordre
état d'urgence et ouvre le feu dans
l'île après la mort d'un leader
indépendantiste eloi machoro pour la
première fois au monde deux médecins
français réalise une transfusion
sanguine sur un foetus qui alpin le
suisse pirmin zurbriggen fait des
merveilles en coupe du monde à kitzbuehl
mesdames messieurs bonsoir les
propositions d'edgard pisani sont et
demeurent raisonnables
c'est en ces termes que le premier
ministre a réaffirmé cet après midi son
soutien au délégué du gouvernement en
nouvelle calédonie après la mort d'un
des leaders indépendantistes et la mise
en vigueur de l'état d'urgence laurent
fabius a également décidé de renforcer
les forces de l'ordre dans l'île des
événements graves viennent de se
produire
la tâche du gouvernement qui a montré
qu'il entend pratiquer le dialogue et de
veiller au rétablissement de l'ordre
public
c'est pourquoi après m'avoir consulté le
délégué du gouvernement a proclamé en
nouvelle calédonie l'état d'urgence la
tâche de la population de
nouvelle-calédonie et de comprendre
qu'on ne gagne rien au cycle infernal de
la violence
je demande à chacun de faire en sorte en
nouvelle calédonie et en métropole que
la raison puisse l'emporter
j'ai examiné cet après-midi même avec le
ministre de l'intérieur et le ministre
de la défense nationale la situation
j'ai décidé d'envoyer immédiatement en
nouvelle calédonie un millier d'hommes
en renfort pour la protection de l'ordre
public
ces renforts porteront les effectifs de
crs et de gardes mobiles à 3280 hommes à
cela s'ajoutent les 3000 militaires
stationnés dans l'île auquel edgard
pisani peut faire appel
en application de l'état d'urgence c'est
donc la mort la nuit dernière des lois
macherot l'un des leaders des
indépendantistes qui est à l'origine de
cette crise une mort qui s'ajoute à
celle d'un jeune caldoches survenu
quelques heures plus tôt très vite ces
deux événements bouleverser la situation
dans l'île le reportage de notre envoyé
spécial
fernand tavarès depuis plus de 24 heures
nouméa et placé sous haute surveillance
après une nuit particulièrement agitée
les violences ont redoublé très tôt ce
matin aux quatre coins de la capitale
des colonnes de fumée indique est à la
fois les points d' incendies des tirs de
grenades lacrymogènes et de cocktails
molotov
cette atmosphère de guérilla entretenu
pendant de longues heures par les anti
indépendantistes
ciman contenus par les forces de l'ordre
mobilisées au grand complet
les affrontements ont fait de part et
d'autre une cinquantaine de blessés plus
ou moins grièvement atteints et puis
vers 10 heures du matin heure locale
c'est-à-dire minuit heure de paris
le maire de nouméa réunissait un millier
de personnes pour leur annoncer la
confirmer
cette nouvelle de la mort des lois
macherot leader de la tendance dure du
fln ks tombeur de thio provoque un
mouvement de détente on voit même des
nouméens manifester soudain des signes
de sympathie envers les gardes mobiles
dont les collègues sont venus à bout de
la bête noire des anti-indépendantistes
eloi machoro 40 ans avait été nommé
ministre de la sécurité du gouvernement
provisoire de nouvelle calédonie former
le 25 novembre dernier par jean marie
tjibaou eloi machoro est tombée ce matin
armes à la main sous les balles des
forces de l'ordre venus dégager une
ferme située à la fois fermes encerclé
par un groupe de mélanésiens conduit par
eloi machoro celui ci a préféré mourir
plutôt que de se rendre au cours d'un
procès qui lie à une situation coloniale
alors qu une situation coloniale qui
profite à une certaine partie de la
population à la bourgeoisie essaie de
vous choisi a fait au soft par les
partis politiques par leur fuite a fait
en sorte qu'il y ait une barrière entre
les kanaks et les noms pana si bien que
la situation est à n'a jamais au lieu et
à l'heure actuelle si nous sommes sur le
terrain ses projets justement faire en
sorte que cette situation change
pour parer une autre flambée de
violences qui auraient pu provoquer
cette nouvelle de la mort des lois
macherot et tenter d'imposer un retour
au calme edgard pisani décrété
solennellement l'état d'urgence pour
rendre possible la recherche d'une
solution d'avenir pour protéger
l'immense majorité des calédoniens qui
souhaitent vivre et travailler en paix
j'ai décidé de déclarer l'état d'urgence
dans un premier temps cette annonce
officielle n'était pas suivie d'effet
une station service appartenant à un
vietnamien soupçonnés d'être proches du
fn heynckes était un sentier toutes les
voitures qui stationnée dans le parking
voisin ont été également détruites
le stock de bouteilles de gaz a pu être
heureusement dégagé à temps peu après le
président du gouvernement monsieur di
luca est intervenu à son tour pour
tenter de ramener à la raison
l'ensemble de la population
je demande solennellement à tous les
calédoniens de rester vigilant dans le
cadre des consignes de sécurité que nous
avons données relatives à la défense des
personnes et des biens
conséquence politique de ces événements
la concertation difficilement engagée
par le haut-commissaire semblent
réduites à néant
jean marie tjibaou ne reprendra pas de
sitôt le chemin du haut commissariat
le numéro un du fln k s a déclaré qu'il
rejetait en bloc toutes les propositions
de monsieur edgar pisani en raison je
cite de l'assassinât des lois macherot
un acte at il précisé qui n'empêchera
pas la poursuite de la lutte pour
l'indépendance du peuple kanak
oui ce soir à paris dans les milieux
gouvernementaux où on estime que les
fils ne sont pas rompues et que edgar
pisani reprendra ses consultations dès
le début de la semaine prochaine
parmi les nombreuses réactions à ces
événements je vous propose d'écouter
celles de maxime gremetz pour le parti
communiste et celle de monsieur jacques
lafleur pour le rpr de nouvelle
calédonie la violence entraîne toujours
la violence ayant permis à certaines
personnes de faire tout et n'importe
quoi
eh bien je pense que les limites
hermies ils ont été dépassés par éloi
match oraux et que ayant lui-même tiré
sur les forces de l'ordre
on ne pouvait pas laisser indéfiniment
les forces de l'ordre se faire tirer
comme des lapins elles ont réagi et ait
eu des victimes
et je le déplore tristesse et profonde
tristesse parce que des hommes sont
morts pour la défense de leurs droits
légitimes et pour leur dignité
indignation à l'égard de l'attitude des
formations de droite qui ont exprimé une
fois de plus leurs sentiments
néocolonialistes ou parti socialiste
lionel jospin déclare que le plan pisani
se justifie plus que jamais quant à
jacques toubon il a annoncé que le rpr
prendrait des initiatives face à la
gravité de la situation sans préciser
lesquelles enfin l udf jean pierre
soisson a déclaré approuvé
l'instauration de l'état d'urgence en
nouvelle calédonie le jour vient tout
juste de se lever
maintenant voyons avec fernand tavarès
comment s'est déroulée cette première
nuit à nouméa nuit marquée par l'état
d'urgence et bien sûr le couvre-feu le
méat vient de vivre sa première nuit
sous l'état d'urgence
les dispositions prévues à cet effet
comme on prépare et artisanes y ont été
scrupuleusement respectée et 19 heures
en dehors des titulaires des
laissez-passer officiel pratiquement
plus personne ne circulait en ville à 3
heures du matin les rues étaient
totalement déserte à peine pouvait
distinguer ici ou là quelques
silhouettes de gardes mobiles effectuant
une ronde les anti indépendantistes ont
donc répondu positivement à l'appel au
calme et à la discipline
lancé par le maire rpr de nouméa rangée
de la roque à nouméa tente comme sur
l'ensemble du territoire où a été
proclamé l'état d'urgence cette accalmie
devrait se poursuivre ce week end où les
uns continueront de panser leurs plaies
tandis que d'autres pleureront et
enterreront leur mort les obsèques du
jeune homme de 17 ans tuée hier doivent
se dérouler dans quelques instants
c'est à dire vers 22h30 heure de paris
quant aux obsèques des lois majoro elle
devrait avoir lieu dans une tribu des
alentours
piot a une patte
voilà tout ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir
sur la situation en nouvelle-calédonie
première mondiale dans le monde de la
médecine cela s'est passé à clermont
ferrand
deux médecins ont réussi à faire une
transfusion sanguine sur un foetus
cela s'est passé au mois de novembre
dernier est aujourd'hui bien l'enfant
est né l'enquète de fr3 clermont ferrand
stéphanie est né il y à un mois jusque
là rien d'extraordinaire
et pourtant pourtant à cause d'une
différence de résultat il a fallu
procéder dans le ventre de sa mère au
changement complet de son sang l'équipe
clermontoise s'est appuyé pour cette
première mondiale sur deux techniques
lui une fondée sur un contrôle optique
dans l'utérus l'autre utilisant
l'échographie mais limité à des
ponctions du cordon sur ce schéma tout à
fait simple vous allez comprendre
nous introduisons une aiguille à travers
la paroi abdominale et à travers la
paroi utérine et dans le cas de ce prêt
si dans le cas précis de ce schéma à
travers le placenta et sous repérage
échographique que vous verrez tout à
l'heure nous pouvons introduire cette
aiguille dans le cordon et par le biais
de cette église poussé un petit tuyau
qui va nous permettre d'injecter et de
retirer le sens au cours de cette
exsangue hymne aux transfusions
comme nous savions que le procédé allait
demander plusieurs heures nous avons
préféré c'est une des originalités du
procès d introduire ce petit cathéter
souple ce qui nous semble diminuer les
risques d'effraction du cordon et
d'hémorragie secondaire ce texte
sanguine ou transfusion a été renouvelée
trois fois jusqu'à la naissance de
stéphanie à la 34ème semaine la maîtrise
de cette technique par l'équipe
clermontoise est donc parfaitement
démontré le fait d'être capable
maintenant de ponctionner du sort du
foetus de pouvoir changer ce sens de
pouvoir injecter des médicaments va
ouvrir une ère nouvelle qu'on peut
appeler une biologie foetale nous allons
être capables comme pour vous une prise
de sang de faire des prises de sang
foetus de lui injecter le médicament
dont ils pourraient avoir besoin de
façon urgente et puis surtout de mieux
connaître la vie foetale qui jusqu'ici
était quand même relativement mai
nuit de nous et
touche pas touche pas à mon pote
peut-être avez-vous déjà vu ce badge
c'est celui d'une nouvelle association
qui s'appelle sos racisme et qui a pour
parrain des gens comme costa gavras
michel hidalgo
françoise gaspard ou bien à bernard
stasi son but lutter contre le racisme
en dehors des circuits classiques
s'adresser aux jeunes aient utilisé un
langage direct à longeur elle ce vaste
racisme sos racisme c'est d'abord une
permanence téléphonique pour écoute et
les agressions physiques ou verbales
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres à minuit
des appels souvent anonymes mais qui
peuvent être un premier pas pour sortir
de l' isolement
la démarche refusé le racisme comme une
fatalité de la vie quotidienne oui
deuxième étape pour ceux qui le
souhaitent une assistance juridique
ici on le dit sans fard le racisme est
un délit
il faut faire appliquer plus souvent la
loi de 72 un langage direct pour la
dernière née des associations anti
racisme qui n'entend pas pour autant
concurrencer ses grandes soeurs
le mrap et la ligue des droits de
l'homme se sont penchées sur son berceau
mais sos racisme a choisi un autre
créneau
même si les phénomènes racistes ont
existé depuis très longtemps il y a
maintenant un certain nombre de jeunes
qui commencent à eux aussi reprendre
l'idée que finalement un arabe ça va
trois arabes
bonjour les dégâts j'ai un comparable
mais lorsqu'il ya trois familles arabes
dans mon escalier
ça fait trop et c'est une minorité
encore mais c'est quelque chose qui est
trop grave pour qu'on laisse passer
pourquoi n'avoir pas rejoint le mrap la
licra ou la ligue des droits de l'homme
mais pense que il y à un certain nombre
de jeunes qui
pour l'instant ne ressentent pas la
nécessité ou n'arrivent pas à
s'accrocher à ce qui existe comme
organisation c'est pas très mobilisateur
peut-être pour alors que si on part de
ce qui se passe tous les jours
là où on vit eh bien on arrive
facilement à s'apercevoir que on peut
exprimer le fait qu'on refuse le racisme
sans avoir besoin forcément d'adhérer de
se structurer de façon très précise les
rouleurs de convergence 84 eux aussi
avaient accepté le soutien logistique
des organisations traditionnelles tout
en gardant leurs distances
une raison à cela les jeunes issus de
l'immigration ont pris conscience qu'ils
représentent à eux seuls un poids
politique
en 86 ils seront 1 million à voter pour
la première fois série noire pour les
mauvais garçons de marseille un homme
qui était connu des services de police a
été abattu ce matin à la sortie d'un bar
c'est la quinzième victime de règlements
de comptes dans le milieu marseillais en
six mois à l'étranger a noté à beyrouth
une explosion qui s'est produite ce soir
dans le secteur de hamra il y aurait au
moins sept blessés
ce matin déjà et toujours à
beyrouth-ouest deux explosions avaient
fait trois morts et 36 blessés
une nouvelle vedette du ski
internationale vient de naître à
kitzbuehl en autriche il s'agit de
pirmin zurbriggen
c'est un suisse et il vient de remporter
les deux descentes de la célèbre piste
de la streif le portrait de cette
nouvelle étoile du ski alpin avec daniel
lauclair
pirmin zurbriggen est bien la nouvelle
étoile du ski alpin en l'espace de 24
heures ce suisse de 22 ans originaire du
valais a réussi un formidable doublé
enlevé les deux descentes de kitzbühel
des allures de kamikazes des pointes à
140 kilomètres heure il faut avoir le
coeur bien accroché
un exploit que seul avant lui ont
réalisé les autrichiens 15 france et ses
poils cher mais au delà d'être l'homme
de la streif pirmin zurbriggen a aussi
prouvé qu'il était un athlète complet
cet hiver il s'est imposé en descente en
slalom et en spécial performance
qu'aucun champion n'a réalisé depuis
jean claude killy en 1968
pirmin zurbriggen très mystique il va
chaque année en pèlerinage à lourdes en
pleine ascension
la superstar
il y avait un loto aujourd'hui il
fallait jouer les numéros 46 41 32 33 34
41 46 et le numéro complémentaire est le
il y avait également un tiercé cet après
midi à vincennes dans le prix de forez
la combinaison gagnante et le 12 le 9 et
le 15 elle rapporte dans l'ordre et pour
cinq francs 3077 francs 50 et dans un
ordre différent 617 francs 50
demain il y aura un tiercé à vincennes
dans le prix de roy 19 partants voici
les préférés de monsieur courtine le 16
ne l'oubliez pas c'est le joker puis les
19 12 10 15 11 et 13
plus de deux cent soixante voitures les
unes dans les autres
4 carambolage en allemagne ont fait 13
morts et plus de 60 blessés cela s'est
passé sur une autoroute entre bonn et
cologne
ces accidents ont eu pour origine le
brouillard qui s'est abattue avec une
grande rapidité sur toute la région
les dégâts matériels sont évalués à 15
millions de francs à ce brouillard a
succédé une véritable tempête de neige
qui perturbe l'ensemble de la
circulation en république fédérale
d'allemagne
en ce qui concerne la france paul quilès
le ministre des transports a conseillé
cet après midi aux français d'éviter de
prendre la route pendant tout le
week-end cela nous amène bien sûr à la
météo pour demain il n'y aura pas
beaucoup de modifications des gelées
encore un peu partout avec des risques
de verglas
le ciel sera nuageux sur presque tout le
pays en particulier sur le massif
central et le sud-est seul l'ouest
connaîtra quelques éclaircies les
températures seront stationnaires
le thermomètre devrait grimper au dessus
de zéro mais seulement en bretagne voit
la fin de ce journal dans quelques
instants vous retrouverez dynastie et
tout de suite après la vie de château de
jean claude brialy très bonne soirée
donc sur fr3 nous nous retrouverons
demain à 22h en attendant voici le
rappel des titres que nous avons
développées au cours de ce journal bonne
soir
crise en nouvelle calédonie laurent
fabius annonce l'envoi de renforts afin
d'assurer l'ordre pour la première fois
au monde deux médecins français réalise
une transfusion sanguine sur un foetus
une étoile est née en ski alpin le
suisse pirmin zurbriggen qui fait des
merveilles en ce moment en coupe du
monde